Wesley first of all commiserations this
is not the way you wanted to see this
match and what are your feelings right
now well first of all big
congratulations to Hikaru I think it's a
well-deserved Victory I mean we both
made mistakes I mean after such low
matches but uh I think he's an extremely
strong player on all time controls and
in crucial moments especially in Blitz
he had a big advantage so yeah big
congratulations Tim I'm not really
that sad I mean I think I fought hard I
think I was playing very decently I had
some chances here and there
but the end of the day that's what chess
is about and just gotta keep trying I
mean it's unfortunate that you had to
end like this with my queen getting
trapped
but at that point I was already kind of
tired from playing day in day out and I
was pushing but uh really it was today
we really was a coin toss anything could
have happened but if it gets to the
Armageddon I think he carries a big
Advantage so I had to find a way to you
know you've took uh hegar all the way
until the final stretch and I have to
say you were putting a lot of pressure
in that 10 plus five section at least
that's how it felt for us in all three
matches even in this one yeah that's the
first game with the white pieces that
end game uh Bishop Knight and a few
pawns but it still felt like you have a
lot of pressure did you feel like you
were winning at anything oh that the
first and the first 10 plus five game
today yes no I don't think I was ever
winning I think he made some mistakes he
had a very good preparation in the
opening
but I don't think I was ever winning
like it was making mistakes maybe there
was this moment right here I didn't see
any win at all when you played Knight
takes B7 you had this move Bishop to A3
which puts a lot of pressure on him if
he takes then you go Knight to five
Knight D7 you're taking the 98.
Oh I thought I missed after King D7
Knight B7 96 I missed I have 1999 C5
it's still not over by the way he has to
take and then go Knight to D4 but this
is not going to be an easy defense oh
also after Bishop A3 yes I thought
Knight G6 Knight G6 Knight to F5 yeah I
missed also on this Knight the five King
F7 Bishop C5 yeah I think I saw
something like this I thought he could
take on C5 basically Bishop B8 Bishop D6
Bishop A7 and then the bishop get
strapped yeah Bishop A3 yeah but nothing
I was already quite happy with the
position like the way I was out playing
him
and I just didn't see Bishop yeah I
didn't uh
I thought yeah Bishop eight there I was
thinking D7 the Knight gets to E6 and
then I stopped yeah yeah not an easy
move to assess especially with like two
minutes and 30 seconds yeah one thing
I'm okay
a much better time management than me in
in all formats so uh in the beginning
it's not a big deal because when you get
a good position it doesn't matter but in
the end it matters when I had a few
seconds
guys yeah first of all Wesley thank you
very much indeed I I know it's been a
challenging uh grueling start to the
year as you've been playing uh
back-to-back-to-back tournaments but uh
your your play here was really a joy to
behold uh very very much so and uh
really I I wanted to ask you about the
format because uh this is the only
tournament that uses this double
elimination format but as a commentator
it's so much fun to call this this this
event would you like to see this format
being used for example for a U.S
championship
oh us championship for example well
that's very interesting I mean I
think the U.S Championship has been the
same as I've been around Swiss
or last year was 13 but yes it has been
the same 11 around round robin for a
long time right other than a few
exceptions right uh
um
yeah it's hard to say I mean this
tournament was very exciting and the
American Cup is even stronger than the
US Championship because it's very
exclusive so it could very well work
um for me personally I kind of like this
double elimination format that way if
you lose you can always come back
and um
um if you have an off day you can fight
hard the next day
and also it's become quite popular
recently online also in the Berlin
Armageddon series
so it could it could very well
uh
work for sure
but then No One's Gonna Break Fisher's
record
nine championships Jovi uh for our
runner-up Wesley is always good yeah no
I'd like to say congratulations Wesley
and
what is next for you you've been paying
a lot of chess
yeah now I have uh I have some break
well there's some online tournaments in
between the Champions Chester
but uh you probably be commentating that
right if I'm correct
will you be commented
I'm going to Germany but yeah that one I
play live on Iranian in division one I
think it starts in a week or something
okay and then I have quite a long break
probably watch Hikaru play title Tuesday
and then after grantchester starts
actually I have a very
tough schedule ahead of me and playing
in the Romania
which is a classical tournament and then
I'm playing in Poland which is rapid
Blitz and then I'm playing in Norway
chess
which is extremely strong with Magnus
Fierce yeah Hikaru Fabiano Etc
so I have to prepare but um
I mean I'd like to say to say thank you
to all the people who made this event
possible I think first of all to the St
Louis chess club and then throw all
three of you thanks for all the
heartbreaking to the referees especially
Chris bird and Judith satire they've
been extremely helpful and also to my
mother who's always encouraging me
amongst many others and again big
congratulations to Hikaru for well the
third win and also Irina I
I looked at her games here and she's
incredibly tough and she managed to beat
Alex Lee and come back Victory so that's
uh that's good now as for me I'm trying
to again focus on my classical chess so
you know wrap it in Blitz is just I mean
it's good if I do well but trying to
play better Chef Wesley congratulations
on an incredible tournament yeah also
congratulations to Fabiano for winning
today's place
last and last the last uh before we let
you say goodbye Wesley oh I'm a fake
yeah so it's your fault I lost this last
game
thinking of you
I only played 95
getting low on the time and you took the
pawn yeah I didn't want to keep playing
you know shorter time control so I
thought either I win or I lose
[Music]
but I wanted to I wanted the rumor on
the street just saying the rumor on the
street is that yesterday you had signed
up for the blitz not realizing you were
gonna prolong the match is that true
that you were ready to play Blitz today
I don't know but it was just the rumor
the rumor on the street yeah I ran into
my Comer on the street and I was asking
him where the blitz was gonna be okay so
you were ready to play some Blitz if it
came down to it right yeah maybe
maybe it's not too late now
at Wesley you've got a lot a lot of fans
uh in the Chess World congratulations
and good luck on what sounds like a very
very tough schedule ahead for you yeah I
think because also Magnus is playing in
Romania in in Norway so wow
I don't think Magnus is playing but we I
read some okay
all right again congratulations and
again uh for us it was really great